le bon Dominique directeur de l'activité
pour les magasins eshop je travaille
pour la marque Apple depuis plus de 15
16 ans maintenant je m'occupe de
l'activité shop pour les deux points de
vente aujourd'hui à Saint-Gilles et à
Saint-Denis
les magasins shop donc spécialisés dans
les produits Apple on a une
particularité c'est qu'on a mis en avant
le service c'est tout ce qui tourne
autour des produits Apple notamment tout
ce qui est une gamme d'accessoires des
accessoires pour les iPad des
accessoires pour les ordinateurs que ce
soit pour le monde professionnel ou pour
les particuliers on a des produits un
peu plus spécialisés dans le monde de la
MAO également donc par exemple on est
capable d'équiper des studios de
création audio montage ou montage vidéo
donc ça c'est des particularités que
nous sommes les seuls à voir sur la
Réunion aujourd'hui Shop c'est une
équipe de 16 personnes nous avons six
personnes pour la partie commerciale 5
personnes pour la partie SAV le reste
administratif on a une petite partie de
ce personnel comme ça qui est passionné
par l'audio donc sur Saint-Gilles et
Saint-Denis nos clients peuvent
découvrir tout l'univers de la création
musicale
aujourd'hui e Shop est en période de
recrutement notamment pour un poste de
vendeur magasin sur le point de vente de
Saint-Denis on a besoin de personnes
ayant une affinité avec les produits
Apple donc toute la gamme que ce soit
les iPad les
iPad les tablettes les ordinateurs
d'Apple voir les téléphones
cette personne aura en direct nos
clients particuliers et également les
clients professionnels
le vendeur en magasin devra préparer la
surface devant avoir une bonne
connaissance des produits savoir
conseiller le client avoir le sourire et
une tenue soignée avoir le sens du
service et faire preuve d'une grande
polyvalence
est à la recherche d'un commercial grand
compte pour toute la partie
professionnelle le client c'est un poste
à pourvoir sur la période de l'année
2015 on a besoin donc d'une personne qui
une grande affinité avec les produits
Apple les solutions Apple toutes les
solutions professionnelles de type Adobe
serveur et tout ce qui tourne autour des
besoins de nos clients
le commercial Grand contre devra faire
preuve de leadership savoir travailler
en réseau être autonome savoir collecter
l'information client adopter une posture
de service savoir négocier communiquer
et présenter avec conviction